wir schauen in die Ukraine das Land ist
wieder mit raketenalarm aufgewacht
wieder Sirenen wieder Explosionen und
wieder Zerstörung heute morgen eine
Reihe von Explosionen in der
ukrainischen Hauptstadt Kiew und
währenddessen melden die Behörden auch
im Norden im Osten und in der zentralen
Ukraine ebenfalls Raketenangriffe
augenzeugen berichten es sei ebenfalls
auch wieder in dem vom Kernkraftwerk in
saporicia dort auch wieder zu Angriffen
gekommen
ja und wir schauen auf eine weltberühmte
Waffe die modifizierte
ak-474 hat gleich zweimal einem Soldaten
ja das Leben gerettet in der Ukraine an
der Front und ein Video davon das geht
jetzt viral
Bild hat den Soldaten hinter dieser
Waffe getroffen sein Codename dentist zu
deutsch Zahnarzt er ist exkommando
Soldat aus Sri Lanka und kämpft jetzt
hier in der Ukraine um die freie Welt zu
verteidigen Dennis zeigt uns ein Video
direkt von der Front
[Applaus]
das ist nie das bin ich
an diesem Morgen wurde ich bereits
getroffen hier werfe ich gerade eine
Granate ohne seine modifizierte AK74
wäre er jetzt vermutlich tot gefallen im
Zweikampf mit einem russischen
Scharfschützen dessen tödliche Kugeln er
abwehren konnte nur sein Bein wurde
verletzt erst als wir uns gruppiert
haben habe ich bemerkt dass meine Waffe
bereits getroffen wurde von einer Kugel
am Ende waren es zwei Kugeln die meine
Waffe abgehalten hat hätte einige
getroffen wäre ich jetzt tot aktuell
befindet er sich in einem ukrainischen
Krankenhaus sobald er wieder laufen kann
bedenkt es zurück an die Front natürlich
mit seinem Gewehr
diese Waffe tausche ich nicht sie ist
mein Glücksbringer sie hat mein Leben
zweimal gerettet
warum er weiter kämpfen wird ist für
dentist glasklar
dies ist ein Land was sich gegen ein
anderes verteidigt
ich glaube dieses Land hat ein Recht
sich gegen den invasor zu verteidigen
dentist ist nur einer von vielen Helden
die den Ukrainern zur Seite stehen um
ihr Land zu verteidigen
[Musik]